por qué
[Música]
hola soy natalia cabrera parada y les
doy la bienvenida aquí a américa este es
el magazine de france 24 para revisar en
profundidad las noticias y las historias
de nuestro continente y esto es lo que
veremos hoy se derrumba el castillo
peruano una vez más el presidente pedro
castillo tuvo que cambiar a su gabinete
tras la renuncia de su primer ministro
aníbal torres que conllevó a la salida
de todos sus ministros les explicamos
esta crisis de gobernabilidad en perú de
la mano de nuestro corresponsal en lima
y en defensa propia las mujeres del
estado mexicano de yucatán toman clases
de boxeo en un país donde diez mujeres
son asesinadas cada día el deporte es la
salida de la violencia doméstica para
algunas de ellas que incluso han llegado
a ganar medallas en los juegos olímpicos
de la juventud
y visitaremos chile donde la decisión
del presidente gabriel boric de vivir en
el centro de santiago lejos de los
sectores adinerados ha desatado un alza
en el turismo en un barrio patrimonial
y vamos a empezar con la cifra de la
semana 5 ese es el número de veces que
el presidente de perú pedro castillo ha
cambiado a su gabinete de ministros en
apenas un año el nuevo episodio de la
serie de crisis que atraviesa el país
llegó con la renuncia del primer
ministro aníbal torres que obliga a
todos los ministros a presentar la suya
el quinto cambio de gabinete deja en
evidencia una vez más no sólo la
dificultad para gobernar del mandatario
peruano sino la ingobernabilidad de la
nación que ha tenido precisamente cinco
presidentes en cinco años
castillo es el primero en ejercicio en
ser investigado por la fiscalía no sólo
en uno sino también adivinen en cinco
casos cuatro de ellos activos justamente
esta semana el mandatario acudió ante el
ministerio público junto con sus
abogados y defendió su inocencia de
presunto tráfico de influencias en el
caso de los ascensos en las fuerzas
armadas
a decir que no soy parte y no formo
ninguna red felina
eso lo he dicho el día de hoy a la
fiscal de la nación y le dicho que voy a
demostrar en cualquier espacio aquí allá
y donde sea mi inocencia yo no cometí a
nadie a nadie robado a nadie matado
trazo declaración ante la fiscalía el
congreso peruano le negó el permiso para
salir del país y venir a colombia para
la posición de gustavo petro como
presidente argumentando riesgo de fuga
en medio de los rumores de que pediría
asilo político en el país vecino para
evadir las investigaciones de la
fiscalía en su contra vamos a limar con
nuestro corresponsal francisco zacarías
francisco sigue esta crisis perpetua va
a terminar pedro castillo el mandato el
congreso de perú hasta el momento no
puede reunir los 87 votos que se
necesitan para someter al presidente
pedro casi o a un proceso de vacancia
presidencial sin embargo el parlamento
alista una acusación contra el
mandatario por presunta traición a la
patria por ofrecer una salida al mar
para bolivia en territorio peruano la
estrategia es aprobar la acusación para
luego invocar al artículo 117 de la
constitución peruana que establece que
el presidente puede ser procesado
durante su periodo por traición a la
patria mientras tanto la fiscalía
interrogará pedro casi o el 9 de agosto
por supuesta obstrucción a la justicia y
presunto tráfico de influencias la
permanencia del castillo en la
presidencia de perú se vuelve incierta
sus antiguos colaboradores son hoy sus
principales verdugos bruno pacheco el ex
secretario presidencial lo acusó de
presuntamente cobrar 20 mil dólares en
los ascensos a generales en la policía y
también de recibir ocho mil dólares
procedentes de un empresario para
nombrar a una persona como miembro del
directorio de la empresa estatal de
petróleos según fuentes del ministerio
público la fiscalía de perú acumula
cinco investigaciones seguidas a pedro
casi o en tres de ellas lo acusa de ser
cabecilla de una organización criminal
pero estos cargos no son suficientes
para llevar a casilla a un tribunal
porque el mandatario goza de inmunidad
sin embargo algunos expertos afirman que
existen vías para que el castillo sea
retirado del poder
la primera es invocar a la convención de
naciones unidas contra la corrupción
usando este recurso el dignatario podría
ser suspendido por orden judicial la
segunda alternativa consistiría en que
la fiscal general de perú pide al
tribunal constitucional que elimine la
inmunidad que tiene el jefe de estado y
la tercera vía sería que un ciudadano
interponga un juicio político contra el
presidente casi por infracción
constitucional si la acción logra ser
aceptada el mandatario podría ser
suspendido e inhabilitado del cargo
francisco zacarías desde lima gracias
por la información vamos ahora a méxico
donde el 77 por ciento de las mujeres
denuncia haber sido víctima de acoso
sexual en su vida y más del 65% han sido
víctimas de violencia doméstica en la
península de yucatán en el sureste
mexicano un grupo de mujeres maya ha
encontrado en el boxeo una forma de
autodefensa y de frenar los golpes en la
vida en informes de nuestra corresponsal
katia espinoza
los puños de profunda mujer que antes
sólo servían para restregar la ropa al
lavar o limpiar la cocina se han
convertido en un arma que frenó por
completo los golpes en su vida nuestra
pequeña sufrió violencia doméstica y en
el boxeo encontró el re propio la fuerza
y el coraje para romper con este círculo
[Aplausos]
ya me pegaba por cualquier cosa me
pegaba era el justificado lo que así
pues me sometió a él me llegó el grado
de que me llegó a ganar el miedo yo ya
le tenía terror ese hombre
en este gimnasio de la localidad costera
de seres punto comenzó hace tres años a
crear un semillero de limpias que han
encontrado en el boxeo no sólo una forma
de autodefensa sino la oportunidad de
convertirlas en promesas en este deporte
en el que en méxico ha arrasado incluso
con medallas olímpicas
yo empezara forma esta familia porque
también en mi caso un banco abandonada
por maltrato familiar también mi papá
había bastante los otros tantos mis
niños cuando veíamos que maltrataba
mucho a mi mamá
pequeñas de entre 8 años pero también
mujeres de más de 30 han encontrado en
este lugar un espacio para liberarse y
ganarse el respeto de su comunidad
no tengan la defensa con que protegerse
sin salir miedo salir con miedo a la
calle
o temer de que les puedan hacer algo un
asalto gracias a este deporte ahora
florindo tiene una perspectiva diferente
de vida pues yo lo creía pues la mujer
solo es para la casa y aún así no pues
si es es verdad pero pues no hay que
usar la violencia y pues gracias a ellos
despierten de todo pues así como soy ama
de casa también trabajo mujeres con la
guardia en alto que quieren ser ejemplo
para las demás que intentan romper el
círculo de violencia aprendiendo a
defenderse a donarse el respeto pero
sobre todo a poner un alto a los golpes
ya la posta
y vamos a centroamérica porque crece el
cerco de los gobiernos a las voces
críticas y no se trata de ideologías de
izquierda o de derecha sino de una forma
aparentemente generalizada de callar a
la oposición miren en nicaragua la
policía le impidió al obispo rolando
álvarez salir de la casa cural de
matagalpa para presidir una misa tras el
cierre de varios medios de comunicación
católicos
el religioso acusa al presidente daniel
ortega de querer una iglesia muda que no
denuncie las injusticias en el país
he querido salir a la catedral
a la santa misa pero obviamente las
autoridades superiores no me han dado
permiso no encontramos aquí seis
sacerdotes
seis laicos que los tienen encerrados en
acudí el fisco para que íbamos a
permanecer sin irrespetar a la policía
nunca la hemos respetado mientras tanto
en guatemala comenzó en la audiencia en
contra del periodista josé rubén zamora
quien fue capturado por supuesto lavado
de dinero mientras que organizaciones
internacionales denuncian que se trata
de una violación a la libertad de prensa
pues zamora es un crítico del presidente
alejandro giammatei por sus
señalamientos de corrupción les
mencionaba que el cerco a la oposición
no está relacionado con posturas de
izquierda o de derecha ya que llama te
hayas considerado conservador es una
manera de ser titular
y
[Música]
diferentes personas que
finalmente en el salvador el presidente
de nadie busca le aseguro que es una
opción vive en paz por primera vez en
décadas luego de revelar cifras de la
policía según las cuales no se han
registrado homicidios en los últimos
días con esta declaración bukele
defendió su polémico estado de excepción
que es cuestionado por organizaciones
defensoras de los derechos humanos que
critican que muchas personas fueron
arrestadas bajo el argumento de
pertenecer a pandillas sin hacerlo
realmente se nos quiere vender la idea
que tener militares en las calles en las
comunidades en todos los escenarios
sociales del país es para garantizar
nuestra supuesta seguridad sin embargo
las cifras son las que precisamente
pueden contrarrestar un argumento y
pueden romper pueden hacer detonar esa
burbuja de falsedad de falacia de
mentiras con las que se mantiene el
discurso y la narrativa oficial por esa
razón se ocultan las cifras vamos a
chile donde el presidente gabriel boric
eligió el centro de santiago como lugar
para vivir lejos de los sectores
privilegiados la llegada de boris ha
generado un resurgir del barrio
patrimonial de yungay y un alza en el
turismo especialmente nacional en esa
zona de la capital chilena veamos el
informe de nuestra corresponsal patricia
luna en honor al triunfo de yungay que
había tenido el ejército chileno en la
guerra contra la conferación pero ya de
ahí surge el nombre yungay vive un
renacimiento este barrio de santiago de
chile- que acoge casas patrimoniales
museos y residencias de artistas ahora
también atrae turistas por ser el lugar
que escogió el presidente gabriel boric
para vivir
60 años aproximadamente que el
presidente de la república nos recibe en
el centro de la ciudad es de hecho el
último antes de gabriel boric fue el
presidente de jorge alessandri
la década de los 50 el barrio que eligió
como residencia el presidente más joven
de chile es conocido por su eclecticismo
y por ser el lugar de origen del
intelectualismo chileno no solo en el
siglo xxi no es nueva en el presente
también muchas de estas casonas fueron
utilizadas antiguamente como talleres de
grandes artistas pintores escritores
escultores y el día de hoy también sigue
siendo como tal hay un tour de santiago
que también pasa por la peluquería
francesa la segunda más antigua del
mundo en operación después de una en
inglaterra aquí la llegada de boris les
ha traído seguridad a venir el
presidente trabajó sin más orden porque
hay más presencia policial hay
carabineros constantemente que están
rondando el perímetro del carabinero
nosotros justamente estamos acá él vive
en la otra esquina más abajo entonces
las cosas que yo hoy día más que nada
hubo más orden ciudadano el mítico
restaurante francés del mismo dueño de
la peluquería tiene a boris entre sus
clientes habituales me parece
muy bien porque eso hace que la gente
piense que se siente una persona más que
nosotros cuando tienen una gran mansión
como los demás presidentes que no vienen
el barrio de alto como lo otro
presidente
él es como
como activamente bueno yo no estaba pero
por la historia que yo leyó como
alessandro
miguel sigue denominando a la moneda lo
mismo que hace morís
y esa humildad del presidente genera
confianza en los vecinos y les alegra
que su presencia de más visibilidad al
barrio mejor
en todo lado los habitantes de yungay
esperan que teniendo más cerca al
presidente sea más fácil para el
gobierno entender a la gente del pueblo
y sus necesidades
esperan un cambio de parte de la élite
política a la que hace años la
ciudadanía en chile acusa de estar
desconectada de la realidad
gracias por acompañarme en aquí américa
en la producción estuvo giovanni agudelo
pueden ver esta emisión y las anteriores
en nuestra página web france24 puntocom
por favor envíenme sus comentarios en
redes sociales a la dirección que viene
en su pantalla y para más información de
nuestro continente sigan viendo france24
[Música]
bienvenidos a santiago